nächste Tag ist angebrochen und somit
unser erster offizieller Tag in tok
Jacken konnte man in diesen Wäschekorb
ablegen und ich habe einen Omelette auf
dem tpagaki bestellt und ohne Cappuccino
geht gar nicht ich habe da noch diese
kackhaufenkekse entdeckt fand ich aber
nicht so geil da habe ich mir mein
erstes Onigiri in Japan gegönnt gefüllt
mit Thunfisch und Mayo und das hat
einfach richtig gut geschmeckt eins kann
ich euch sagen in toky werdet ihr nicht
verdursten überall gibt diese Automaten
wo ihr Wasser und andere Getränke kaufen
könnt nächster Stop war dann akiabada
nennt sich auch electric town weil es
einfach überall und an jeder Ecke
technischen Kram gibt ich habe direkt am
Bahnhof einen richtig genialen foodpot
entdeckt diese Teile waren einfach
gefüllt mit pistazio so lecker akabada
ist außerdem noch bekannt für diese
ganzen Gaming Läden hier ist Hanser
seine alten Sucht verfallen aber keine
Sorge ich konnte ihm das ausreden denn
dieses plüst hätte er niemals gewonnen
von den Fotoboxen kann man sich übrigens
noch schick machen hier liegen einfach
Glätteisen rum nach einer kleinen
trommeleinlage und dem Entdecken des
ersten dönerladens in Japan haben wir
noch was richtig cooles gemacht Leute
aber das seht ihr dann beim nächsten
Blog eins kann ich euch auf jeden Fall
verraten es hat was mit Tieren zu tun